physics and cs
uh with as much work and on quantum
complexity theory as from the physics
side and which has lots of work on
quantum hamiltonian complexity error
correction
and then uh it's pleasure to also have
adam
adam recently won the philip meyer prize
in theoretical physics for his work on
which is quite relevant on on the
dynamics of quantum many body systems
especially using uh techniques using uh
involving random quantum circuits
so um
so
uh to to kick off the panel let me just
let me just start by putting out a
somewhat provocative vision along the
you know uh i think that maybe shivaji
had been hinting at but this is this is
at least the way a computer scientist
would look at it so let me let me just
try to see how i view it so uh so
you know you you might say well
how would quantum computers be be useful
well you know we have we have several
ways we could think of it one is well we
are going to solve optimization problems
or things like factoring you know
well-defined computational problems of
that kind
the the other way we could say is well
you know let's let's go back to the fact
that quantum quantum computers would
allow you to simulate quantum mechanics
efficiently and that's surely a very
important thing to do
so
and and what else could there be well
well there's a there's a third way to
look at it which is
if you look at classical computers one
of the things that they provide us with
is is an excellent interface to to the
world
um you know and and then in computer
science terms we talk about the human
hci human computer interface
and so
well if we think about it in the in the
context of of the quantum world then
then this takes on a completely
different different view in the sense
that hilbert space is very large
and the way we could think about it is
that that our experience of this of
hilbert space is mediated through
through
uh you know whichever parts of albert
space are
you know are accessible through the fact
that they are amplified to the classical
world through measurements
and so could it be that um that once we
have quantum computers
that
that this allows us to prove through
a parts of hilbert space that we you
know we wouldn't have been able to probe
otherwise you know so that so that it it
you know that our classical experience
which which we could think of as as
you know as an experience of the parts
of hilbert space that we can normally
we normally have access to you know
could we actually enhance that by
by by mediating it through through a
quantum computer so i i know this sounds
sounds somewhat uh
you know part you know but um
but you know this is one way you could
think about this interactive quantum
dynamics and say
what can we achieve through through this
method so anyway i'll turn it over to
the panelists to take a few minutes to
get their thoughts about about um
you know they may have about shivaji's
talk about and also about anything else
they'd like to like to bring up
so
um almost one comment about what you
just said of course um
you know what the talk that we heard
today which was very nice from shivaji
is not quite like that because often we
have classical predictions and
you know we come with theories and so on
so we're not entirely open to
you know we we want to have a problem
where where the experiment is actually
telling us hey you know
this is going on and now
let's try to explain it better or right
it has to be come first from the
experiment and then
maybe the theorists will have some
classical description of it right
that would be more interesting
um
so so you're saying you're saying
um
um
it it it could be that that um that
that um that the phenomenon would
actually first come up in experiment
before we actually understand it yeah
that would be the more interesting thing
in in because now i think i mean i i you
know i don't want to do i want to do
justice to you know the talk that we
just heard i found it interesting but
it's something where you say well we
expect maybe something like this and now
we're testing this
but it's no it's not it's a confirmation
but of course things get really
interesting when the experiment shows up
things that we
regularities or patterns that we do not
quite understand
it can kind of work
you know work in conjunction in the
sense that you you you sort of uh say
well if you look in this direction we
may find something but then you look you
look for it you find it but then you
find something else as well
so in other words
where do you look where do you start by
looking and uh and and so in in you know
you could sort of say well how um
you know if if we wanted to if we wanted
to use
well first to what extent is it possible
but then if you wanted to use quantum
computers to mediate the search
for for uh
for for sort of
you know isn't it possible that one
could have completely new physical
phenomena
that were not accessible to us because
because the normal mechanisms for
observation would not have revealed them
to us
those phenomena to us but they're now
access they might be accessible just
because we have we have an intermediary
which is a quantum computer
yeah i think that's interesting but
maybe some of the other panelists have
thoughts on this yeah
i i think we are not there yet but i
think
which is that
you know it should be
you know it's a new physical system and
it should do things you know the real
payoff is going to be to run it in
experimental mode
in which you
search and hopefully you need some
cost function which tells you what's
interesting and then you then you go
looking
so
this talk was more to say you know the
way to look at it is perhaps to say
supposing we had had such devices
20 years ago maybe we would have found
time crystals by searching for them
on these devices whereas we couldn't
have found them on you know other
devices so i
mean i absolutely agree with you know
what she said coming back to what you
said i think
as a formal matter
um
right we're going to be looking at a
certain
in the space of
heaven which are made up of this
territory of
you know unitaries and measurements
now
the answer to your question is somehow
buried in there which is to say that if
you were
simulating
you know some aspect of the world
which you normally perceive in a certain
way
you know would you perceive it sort of
differently
if you could if you could go this way so
i think you maybe have to simulate the
world
closer to
the one we live in as opposed to you
know
but in principle
i think they're the same
ultimately any
experiment in the observation you know
it's start somewhere in the end
somewhere
you do some number of things along the
way
[Music]
so so what you're looking for
fits in this larger class of evolutions
somewhere
um
should i pick up on
something
shivaji said at the very beginning
maybe i can ask you
on the connection or something so you um
made a comment at the beginning about
um
you made a contrast with
between quantum computation and the kind
of things we think about in stat mech
in terms of kind of a system which is
sort of statistically homogeneous
everywhere versus
a very highly structured
computation
and um
so i wanted to ask sort of how much if
we want to make a bridge between those
things how much is that a worry
and
or
or might be possible to put
things which are more like real quantum
computations in a statistical mechanics
language
so
for example as a question for quantum
information people
might it make sense to have
sort of random ensembles of algorithms
which look a bit like more like a
statement problem you know in the sense
that we have
in many body physics random hamiltonians
random matrix theory and we can have
random circuits but presumably that's
not anything like what you'd think of as
a computation
but
is it imaginable that you could have
um
random ensembles of
algorithms so you could start to ask in
a statistical mechanics language about
generic properties of
quantum computations and things like
that or are you always going to have
this problem that shivaji mentioned but
a real computation of interest is always
something specific and structured and
there's a disjunction with
the kind of things we think about in
stomach
there's a bit of a vague question but i
just wonder how how close do you think
is that
is that for is that for me or shivaji
i'm i'm not
um it's for anyone here
well i think i can tell from the
experience that uh
there is a
there is a impact and the community of
interest for a given algorithm we do
and then there is a computational
complexity of that algorithm so one time
which we did it successfully
the community of interest became very
very narrow we managed to make big
strings with high fidelity better than
classical computer so we outperform a
classical computer but the community of
interest become very narrow so i imagine
that the next
case
we might solve a problem let's say
related to out-of-time order correlation
or something that would have a slightly
bigger community of interest or bigger
bigger class of group of algorithm so i
think you guys are maybe uh talking a
little more general that you know cost
functions and algorithm in general i
think uh these are
a little further down in the down the
line in the future but i think uh
various specific cases like you know
time crystals or um
highly in
the group of algorithms or the class of
algorithms uh we're gonna gonna um very
slowly grow
and the community of interest is going
to people who care about those cases are
going to very slowly grow
is not going to be very different than
our
quantum supremacy experiment which was
not
you know which was highly contrived to
to beat the classical computer
essentially
so i i think it would be
very similar to that the next the next
milestone
okay maybe as a as a common to adam i
think i i mean i think it doesn't right
we like to you design optimal algorithms
right so it doesn't fit very nicely with
the statistical picture
you know only when you're a very little
child you do random things but you
quickly learn the optimal strategies and
uh but in that sense i think maybe
machine learning and quality machine
learning you have some of that where you
can do some statistics
right but not in the sort of critical
design of algorithms at least i don't
see it
maybe i can ask a question to shivaji
about his talk or about the field a bit
um and this is on the effect of noise
and also related to experiment so
well you made the point you wanted the
things were done to distinguish the
effect of noise and thermalization
um
without you know presence of noise but a
noise can also be you know uh positive
right it is the noise in these devices
is not the polarizing noises necessarily
it's actually if you
leave the device alone uh most cubits
just you know go to their ground state
and with their some you know
there's some fluctuations not entirely
true but not necessarily very high
entropy states
so
you could also have
you know why not include the noise in
the description of these phases or
are there reasons so how does the field
look at noise or lint blood equations so
they say
and and phases in those systems
right
actually
it goes on the call may be able to speak
more precisely to this but you know uh
in terms of different kinds of noise
because uh
she and
their equality
stanford
did a lot of the development
broadly speaking
um
experience has been that
if you add some
fairly general
then the time crystals to be well
defined
is
and so
now
i'm hedging because you raised the
question of you know could there be some
very specific kind of noise which
exists in these devices which could
still leave you i
i know maybe
i know they thought a bit about it and
indeed when we began the experiment part
of the hope was
that the experiment itself
maybe tell us that the error model that
one really should use for these devices
is more specific than
the one that was thought of initially in
the quantum supremacy experiment but
maybe vitica can jump in and speak to
what we learned
at the end of the day that would be
great
oh yeah so i can
maybe say
two things one is um
in indeed you know in the mbl problem
where the problem itself has structure
if your noise also has structure so for
instance in in mbl we have these
conserved operators which mostly look
like they're aligned in the z basis so
if you only had the phasing noise um
which coupled to that z channel that's
that's in a sense less dangerous than
than spin flip noise so there are there
are different kind of
differences in that regard but you know
in this particular platform there was no
reason to expect that
one type of noise is is dominant over
another
um so so then you know the depolarizing
model works pretty well as an
approximation but then let me give a
second
answer to that which is um
[Music]
which shivaji alluded to which is you
know can we
which is the benchmarking business right
so can we
use noise maybe more as a as a feature
rather than a bug right so can we
can we maybe if we wanted to probe the
properties of these l bits for instance
can we can we it is certainly the case
that
you know the effect of noise is is
different depending on what the
intrinsic dynamics and your problem are
to give you an example you know if you
have some noise in some one cubit if
you're in the localized phase the effect
of the noise acts in time but doesn't
really spread out in space
on the thermalizing side the effect of
noise you know spreads over space very
quickly um and that that is what the
supremacy experiment was was plugging
into
so so i think it's a it's a broader uh
question to see you know if you have
different types of noise could we use
that to characterize the
dynamics based on how they couple to the
noise but but at least just for the time
crystal experiment there was nothing
extremely special there
but is there was there a limit because
the time crystal experiment you know
with a certain number of rounds and what
if you would gone uh ten times longer
would you you know would i assume you
believe it be the same it would uh
not be um over dominated by noise is
that right or is this
yeah yeah so okay so so this is um
shivaji didn't delve into this in too
much detail but you know one of the
indeed i mean you you know instead of
decaying exponentially in the space time
volume in the time crystal experiment
you're mostly decaying exponentially in
time because the the effect of the noise
is not is not spreading out too much so
if you wait long enough in a realistic
experiment the signal will go to zero so
some of the things that we did was to
employ kind of time reversal protocols
to try to distinguish between this
intrinsic thermalization and external
noise
so you know so for instance what we did
is we we measured the same
autocorrelators but time evolved with u
dagger u which of course unitarily would
be would be just one
um but
but then what it what it picks up is is
more the
if you get a decay for that
autocorrelator that's coming
dominantly from the noise because if it
is perfectly unitary there would be
nothing
and in in the limit of being deep in the
mbl phase if you kind of
divide out the actual dynamics with this
kind of normalization factor um you you
reproduce what you should get to to very
good accuracy so
so what that means is that um
you know at some point you're going to
hit the noise floor in the experiment
you know so so this this division works
well on on a computer but there you'll
get numerical precision and a lab you'll
hit
measurement precision but but but modulo
those
things yes we could have gone a factor
of two longer in time and and still been
able to see something
it's just a signal to noise ratio you
have to average for a long time
and then at some point we get tired of
averaging
maybe i can ask a question in the
bedroom so
in terms of
the platform i mean
when do you see it impossible to
actually
feedback
it's hard to make promise publicly so
maybe i should definitely not not next
[ __ ] about that
uh we are focusing for pat on passive
error correction currently
um for for active correction you have to
uh bring the time of the readout of the
qubits much closer to the time of the
gate and particularly on the
experiment that you mentioned on your
last minute of talk on measurement
induced the current
challenge for us is that the gates are
about 30 nanoseconds but the time to
measure the state reliably is close to
800 nanoseconds so and the feedback and
the measurement induced transition both
needs a much shorter readout time
and that's a very hard
engineering challenge which we are
working on so
uh i think first you would hear from us
that we have
managed to do shorter readout and then
then these feedbacks would follow
problems
so so in in terms of actually being able
to do an interactive
experiment
that that you would say would
is is a little ways off
yeah i i yeah i think so it's uh
certain engineering challenges are
really
rooted in deep physics that we don't
have good understanding from
um sorry but um
just just pursuing that a little bit
about the interactive aspect so survivor
you you've worked on
some of the complexity theoretic aspects
of interactive
you know experiments so
can you say a little bit about that so
it's in in terms of
well
yeah i mean
you know there are various reasons why
one does these interactive
protocols
well yeah i don't know whether i'm able
to comply in the sense that i haven't
thought about uh interactive proof
systems for example in the in a while i
more think about error correction these
days and that's uh there's a lot of
you there you also need interaction but
uh well not maybe at the first first
rounds
you hope to get all the information
about errors and then leisurely process
this um
yeah i don't know what to say
i'm actually surprising that you
surprised that you do you stress this
interaction because a very old-fashioned
point of view and economy information
was like well if you do a measurement in
the middle
you know you can just replace it by
something quantum and then you know you
then
but of course the point is you're using
you're leveraging the power of classical
computers in this interaction yeah and
that's uh
that's really the thing that makes it
different
well you know i i think that that's
correct um you know
of course that goes back to the very
early days you know when when the
question came up whether
immediate measurements increase the
power of quantum computing
but but now there are there are also
these other issues right having to do
with well i mean you worked on that as
well but uh in terms of uh you know how
do you how do you deal with untrusted
important devices but through
interaction
and how do you
how do you use it to reach into hilbert
space in ways that you would not be able
to do
[Music]
there's a whole new
well i guess you guys have touched on a
lot of this but um
i mean along what barbara was saying
about interaction it does seem like
fault tolerance is a very important case
here
and it's a situation where
where errors don't belong
so
i mean people have talked about it in
sort of vague terms in terms of
but
you know
i guess one interesting thing is that if
you have a generic quantum circuit
like one error in the middle will will
completely randomize the final answer
and then a fault tolerance circuit looks
very different one error in the middle
will have no effect on the final answer
um
and
one
i guess
one related
so yes what is the question one
one question i have
is um
we do
random quantum circuits
as a toy model for a non-error corrected
quantum circuits
um
and
and is there any way to sharpen that
intuition like maybe a
non-error-corrected quantum circuit
where we're just sort of not really
trying to do things
uh maybe there's some way to compress it
so that it really looks even more like a
random quantum circuit you know like
maybe we're not being as efficient with
our degrees of freedom but there's a way
to to compress it so it looks nearly
random
um
i don't know exactly what the right
questions are there but it seems like
there's a vague intuition there that
like we study circuits because they're a
proxy for generic quantum dynamics i
wonder if there's a way to sharpen that
in any way
could you say again what it was you
wanted to compress you you want to start
with a generic random circuit and or you
or you want generic circuit let's say
let's say i have a circuit to you know
factor short algorithm you do shores
algorithm or simulate the transverse
field i see model on a quantum computer
but
there are various tricks that people
have to say
well
you know sometimes we can save a few
qubits here maybe we can model the
circuit as a tensor network and we find
that it's not quite as entangled across
this cut so we could we could compress
this side to fewer cubics
um
there are various papers about
you know simulating large quantum
circuits on smaller quantum computers
and and they hit limits when you could
say it's maybe it becomes hard to
compress because the amount of
entanglement across
uh subsystems becomes nearly maximal so
um
so i'm not quite sure what the right and
now what the right
thing is there i will say
you know for classical
data translation there's a sort of
heuristic idea that sort of generically
if i'm just typing english that's not
full entropy but if i run it through a
data compression algorithm i get
something that's nearly full entropy
and you know maybe that's a start a good
starting point if i'm going to
um
try to use to to encrypt it in a graphic
way
this is all this is all very heuristic
but
um
there's a sense that sort of generic
generic data is not
you know has some entropy but it's not
full entropy but compressing it makes it
nearly full entropy so
you know this is extremely hand-wavy
what i'm saying but
uh i wonder if there's any utility just
trying to formalize any of it
well it's almost like a sort of arcgish
idea that you want to coarse grain and
sort of flow off to a fixed point so you
want a certain circuit go off fully
random
yeah
don't we know that for a generic circuit
you can't compress it very much that it
still has a generically it has a circuit
complexity which is proportional to its
depth just with them
with right which is more than one well
this you know this video call like you
know a generic um
communication message i cannot compress
but yet this video call is compressed
because our you know our faces are not
generic images so
um
that's that's the intuition of you know
maybe many quantum circuits can be
compressed
um
another way of saying that is you know a
lot of these random circuits
they thermalize to infinite temperature
but
you know things are are not always at
infinite temperature um and so there's
that's another way in which the theory
could be could be developed a little bit
more of uh i mean i think there you know
there are there are random circuits that
have conserved quantity so
yeah i don't know if that's the right
direction
sorry
just very quickly um
you you mentioned sort of in one breath
the simulating the isaac model or
something like that and a quantum
algorithm to do a useful task
a computational task but maybe the
question that many of us
statistical physicists would have is how
should we heuristically think of what
those circuits which are doing something
computationally useful look like
and how do they look different to
chaotic evolution of a many-body system
and
that's i don't have any intuition for
that that was sort of what i was trying
to get to
before
yeah i mean it's very complicated enough
others have insight into this but you
know just think about an algorithm that
multiplies two numbers
or does modular exponentiation
in a lot of these if you have one bit
that gets flipped it's going to affect a
lot of other bits and if it didn't then
you could probably paralyze it you know
if you have little blocks and each bit
in there doesn't affect you any other
bits
then that means that there's scope to to
parallelize it um
and that's
so
that's that's sort of like why
i suggest that uh you know
if you've taken advantage of all the
efficiencies you can then then things
you know
that it may start to look look like a
random circuit even though
yeah that's the vague intuition behind
that
yeah
can i can i comment on this or can i
maybe pick up on this
please yeah
yeah so
maybe an answer and a ques to
an attempted answer to adam's question
about a random
ensemble of algorithms and basically
sending this question to the computer
scientists here so if i i take for
example a piece of quantum material
at some reasonable lowish temperature or
energy density and i take it out of
equilibrium
and i let it evolve in time and it's
going to
generate very non-local entanglement
very non-local correlations it's
performing some kind of quantum
computation in the end we can read off
an answer in a set of readout qubits and
the answer will
generically be something like what is
the uh diffusion coefficient of this uh
quantum material right we'll get this
answer and we'll get actually the same
answer no matter what is the disorder
realization in this material as long as
the average disorder is is thinking
so the question is in what sense can
this be
thought of as if we think of this
material as a circuit
uh as as a quantum algorithm as an
ensemble of quantum algorithms that
proves the same answer and we can
somehow try to analyze it in computer
science ways and see if it
has a quantum it gives a quantum
advantage for example is is this an
example of um in symbol of algorithms
that we can actually and have actually
looked at in in statistical mechanics
analysis
well i i don't want to do real things
too much with the compression thing but
one thing you could do in this kind of
low temperature setting is if you could
say well suppose the system has a
some entropy density so that means that
you can take little blocks and compress
them and maybe you can do the then
you can
that could be on your that could the
quantum computer could do that fairly
cheaply perhaps and then the dynamics
could be done
um
you know
that then you could do the dynamics on
this on this compressed space um
and and then even though your the
underlying system is low temperature
that would be gonna be closer to
something where where each qubit looks
closer to maximally mixed now
there's still many many steps from there
to like does it fully look like a random
quantum circuit but that would at least
be
you know getting closer to something
where even though you're simulating a
low temperature system
you
do some fairly
mild compression and you get something
that looks closer to infrared
maybe one comment also coming back to
this error correction full tolerance is
that of course if you have errors in
your circuit you also have an ensemble
of circuits and if it's full tolerant
then you're below threshold and it is
keeping its functionality
right but if you're if you're not or you
haven't designed it well then you are
it's losing its functionality so
i think that that's maybe the best
example i can think of that it's
[Music]
sorry there was a there's a related
point that for shivaji you know when you
spoke about your time crystal experiment
there was there's something that you
brought up which i didn't fully
understand so so you said well
look um
normally you'll be you'd be probing the
you know you're you're being in an
equilibrium phase where you're probing
the low energy states and and here what
you're what you're saying is you you
find ordering throughout the hilbert
space uh you know including at you know
your high energy eigenstate so can you
can you see a little bit more about that
just to
well um
but let me um
let me describe it this way so
you know
this was a flowcare problem but there's
a
similar statement
you know the paper we we first wrote um
you know david hughes and
myself and
i won't list
um
it's called localization protected
quantum order so that one was actually
on the transverse field eisenhower
uh with random bonds and random fields
this is actually a a very well studied
problem there was a lot of work on this
before we came along
now what's interesting is that when you
work on that phase diagram
using
the tools of statistical mechanics if
you say i'll just take that hamiltonian
and calculate the properties of e to the
minus beta h
then
you can't find any order at any non-zero
temperature because that's the
celebrated theorem in
electrical mechanics that you cannot
break a discrete symmetry in one
dimension about zero temperature
so all you have is what you would call
the parameter
so
but when you examine the individual
eigenstates of the hamiltonian
going all the way up uh you know
in energy at least in the in the case
which is described by by free fermion it
gets more complicated
but but it
it doesn't really matter the point is in
the statistical mechanical version what
should have happened was that any
non-zero energy density above the ground
state should have given you no cementite
and in fact you get it at non-zero
energy densities and in this special
case you get it at any energy density
whatsoever so that's the case where you
have a hamiltonian you can be very sharp
because you can define the energy
density with respect to the hamiltonian
but the floquet unitary
right since the unitary
is not really an energy
so it's sort of the but what you can ask
is how close you are to a certain kind
of state maybe you know you start with
let's say all spins up and you get very
far from it but in the case of the
hamiltonian problem the localization
protected order is very striking it
really violates
this theorem which you know goes back to
landau which is that you cannot break
discrete symmetries
at nonzero temperatures in one dimension
continuous symmetries two dimension
that's the movements
and localization allows you to get
around
i don't know is that quite
yeah um i'm not i'm not sure i
completely understood you know so so the
sense i got was that um
you know this was this was exploring the
the high energy part of the spectrum not
just the low energy part so is that
you know to to to what extent is that
unique to this expert you know so is is
that something that um
[Music]
so you know just in terms of well you
know probing hilbert space which parts
can you probe and not prove in
experiments so can you say a little bit
about place this in the in the
you know in context and
sure
so i guess there are two issues one is
as an as an experimental matter if i
give you a solid
right and you try and heat it up it's
got degrees of freedom you know there's
a locally unbounded space so you're
going to keep heating
and
so there's in a sense you don't get to
infinite temperature just because you
know things keep happening
um now
if you have a
model system which which is um
has a locally bounded hilbert space cube
it's
then of course for spin systems or qubit
systems you can
sensibly talk about you know the sort of
configuration which you would think of
as being infinite temperature very high
energy
which is hard to do if you if you can
just keep absorbing energy
forever
so within this more restricted class of
systems which you either will realize to
a good approximation
basically ultimately anything has
degrees of freedom going you know
out forever so what you really need is
that the local degree of freedom comes
with some gap
right so that you're able to sensibly
excite
things below the gap and not not above
it
too much so
once you've accepted this locally
bounded hyperspace description then
you know then there's this distinction
between finding interesting things
happening
for states which are very high energy
with respect to hamiltonian
and
not finding something interesting so in
the traditional understanding of
statistical mechanics
you wouldn't expect to find anything
particularly interesting because the
thermal density matrix at infinite
temperature is just you know e to the
minus beta h with beta equals zero so
you're just taking a totally
unrestricted average
over all states
um
and um
so
so in this case
that the fact that you can see things in
individual eigenstates
eth is the is the other way to look at
it which is to say that every individual
eigen state is supposed to reproduce for
you the statistical mechanical density
matrix
and here
these high energy states don't do that
so there's special states which is where
the localization comes
great
um
this there's one more question from our
second
[Music]
hi hi shivaji
hi
nice to see you um
so i wrote the question down so it's
hopefully clear
tfnp is the complexity class which
contains np problem
problems with the property that every
input has a witness i hope that makes
sense
so there are np problems for which it is
guaranteed that there is uh like a
witness that satisfies the problem right
that's a special
uh subclass of np
uh there seems to be a connection of the
to the topic of the talk today in the
sense that in the relevant phase that
you
mentioned there is always a periodicity
uh but i'm wondering if there is um
hard or interesting computational
problem
uh that might be hiding here for example
um
finding
the the um
you mentioned that there is a time limit
under after which
you would get back to your original
state for example so for example maybe
it's hard to find that time
um
you also mentioned that there are pairs
there so maybe you know given one state
find it's you know it's evil twin things
like that
um
i i'm not sure if the second problem
made sense
i i'm actually have to say as i'm
reading i i have as you'll remember from
the old days a very limited
understanding of such matters so
i tend to think of a witness mostly i
think
um so i guess this is the kind of
witness is not a solution and it's still
still hard that's so big can i kind of
translate slightly
go ahead go ahead so
correct me or uh if i'm getting this
wrong but but um
but
maybe what what what ora is saying is
that look um
you know you have these systems where
you're saying
you know you're driving them at a
certain certain frequency but then you
see period some other completely
different period show up uh in terms of
the dynamics
um or there's some other pattern that
shows up so there's some pattern that
shows up once you actually do the
quantum revolution and the question is
well
is is is this something that might
actually be hard to
find you know so so in other words you
set up the system and you have no idea
what this what this pattern is and once
you you know once you find it you can
verify it and so on but uh
you know could it be that these are hard
computational problems hiding in in
yours in your in the definition of your
system
i mean it's an
really interesting talk because in terms
of using the these systems
as experimental devices and going
hunting for interesting things
i think aura's question would come up
namely if you saw something interesting
would you would you recognize it
um
right which is i mean
physicists
tend to have a standard you know we tend
to think about the correlation functions
local expectation values you know
looking for certain kinds of order we
have a list of things and you could
imagine looking for that
um
yeah i don't know just like for a
concrete example do you know how hard it
is to find the period itself like the
the time in which the periodicity
appears
uh again maybe i'm not getting the
that's the real question but you know
something like periodicity and you're
putting a transform when you look for a
peak i mean generally finding a period
in some time series
isn't that big a deal as long as the
quantity that in who you're looking for
a period is relatively easy to measure
now
maybe sorry i think
[Music]
if i understand correctly or is asking
you know so suppose you suppose you had
a certain experiment in mind
would you be able to predict what period
you should see before you actually
perform the experiment or would it be
the experiment that reveals it to you
and that you know if you if if you were
trying to compute it especially if you
were trying to compute it classically
you wouldn't have a hope uh you know is
that is that possible in this in the
kinds of systems that you were looking
at
okay so
let me try and repeat it in a way that i
think i understand so is the question
supposing you had it you had a set of
local unitaries
which certainly need a fundamental
period to begin with
and the question is
does the actual evolution show some
multiple or some you know
do something else does it break that
time translation symmetry in some way
and
can you say in advance i mean how easy
would it be to
you know to understand it i
i don't know i mean it's the
a good question i mean it because
in the limit of a large system you have
a
and it's like a huge hamiltonian unitary
right i mean it's uh
any naive before it certainly is not
going to be
in this case as barbara said at the
start you know if you knew what we were
doing what you're asking
are there other things uh i i don't
that doesn't seem easy to me maybe
someone else has an answer but the
disorder is also important here right
shivaji you have to have you have a
family of hamiltonians with this sort of
right and that's what makes average
quantities that's part of the question
you don't have to average because every
single disorder realization will
eventually show this behavior at long
times
but you're going to have to wait a long
time before you see it so that's what
the phenomenon is robust but one reason
it's difficult to guess is because it's
not something that just stares you in
the face when you start it's not a few
period phenomena it's a long time
large system phenomenon
if there were other things like that
they might well be hard too
yeah actually that also leads to the
question that i had is indeed that um
you know for what other hamiltonians
come on make these predictions because
you know this of course is uh zz and
then a transfer field that this that is
matching the experiment very well but
are there other candidates um that
people have been looking at and that are
experimentally
um you know close or say
of course you could they make small
variants of these circuits that are
i mean i don't know if another okay
hamiltonian very different which is you
know it's predicted to show period
doubling their other flowcase which show
other periods you know i mean part of
this class of things this is the
simplest one
great so i think we are we are
approaching the end of the panel period
so if if anybody has any quick thoughts
on the panel or
anything else to add
actually maybe again since bedroom is
here
you mentioned that
800 to
eight
nanoseconds of the champion
can you
tell us what the what the physics
challenges are that
sort of
um because the
right um because uh there is a qubit and
you read out the state by coupling it
with a linear resonator if you couple it
strongly so and then you're looking for
the state of that resonator
to be
their frequency resonance frequency of
that resonator shifts a little bit
depending on your qubit to be occupied
by is it zero or one shift that
resonance frequency a little bit and
you're looking for that shift
so uh but since you want to read it out
that's a
challenging balance
that if you couple it strongly so you
can quickly read it out but then you
decohere your system faster if you
couple weekly then you have to integrate
for longer time to recognize how much
the resonance frequency have shifted so
uh uh that that's the challenge uh and
it is a big challenge for error
correction but
for nisk usually when you would have
measurement at the end
it's not a challenge yeah i mean it's
major challenge for feedback
but i hope we can come up with lots of
exciting physics that you just need to
read the states of cubit once at the end
great um
well
maybe um yeah we can
you know that was
possibly this is a good
stop so uh thanks everybody thanks thank
you especially uh
you know adam barbara and pedram for for
being on the panel and thank you shivaji
for
and of uh
thanks to the audience for
for uh great questions
thank you for inviting us off to join
thank you very much thank you
thanks a lot thanks bye